you can walk into my office it is
uppercase and I can handle it no matter
what you use we don't give up
this is JJ arms and he's maybe the
world's most famous private investigator
I don't say that I am people say that I
am back in 1958 arms founded the
investigators the investigators is a
company that was established by J arms
to conduct every type of investigation
would cover the whole spectrum in like
all legendary heroic figures J is
triumphed over tragedy when I was 11
years old a friend gave him over to my
home I had a box of dynamite caps they
exploded had rolled my hands off at the
wrist so young J was outfitted with
prosthetics and he managed to turn a
negative into a positive
exactly here's JJ arms petting his white
Siberian tiger Simba here he is this 53
year old pet chimp gypsy and he was
[ __ ] with J son J so J how many cases
have you solved hundreds of cases all
over the world he'd be a little bit more
specific you ask an artist how many
paintings to be done he can tell you
I've done 20 paintings or 200 paintings
I take my craft like an artist and he's
had some pretty famous clientele most
famous his was Marlon Brando
he says J somebody has kidnapped my son
Christian he gave me the information
with the boy was kidnapped from legend
has it that JJ arms tracked down
Christian to the jungles of Mexico
flying his helicopter and staying up for
five days without food or water until he
came upon a camp with eight armed men
I'm coughing in the
and I went into the little tent that was
a Christian Brando
he didn't know me he sees this guy with
two hooks so he thought I was one of the
bad guys
I said no no your father hired me for JJ
arms what was once an impediment has
become an asset and has led to a long
fruitful career I've been doing this
type of work for over 45 years how old
you Jay
oh I'm about 150 150 but I'm really
hundred fifty at not 150 it's safe to
say most of JJ arms adventures are
behind him but he's not slowing down
anytime soon
no I have more work now than ever
Jay do you see yourself as a legend how
do you wanna be remembered oh my
obituary Jay Arms did it his way one
liner that's it